I am a long snapper on the football team
which means on punts I'm the guy who
snaps 15 yards and I'll feel well as I'm
a guy who snaps back though my name is
Patrick EB I am in Columbia College
majoring in psychology and I'm
graduating May 2019 what Coach Spagnola
and all the staff members he brought in
what they did for this program is
nothing short of a miracle and being a
part of that resurgence was arguably the
best it was the best thing I will ever
be a part of because they set the goal
of being the best Colombian football
team in the history of the school and
given that we've been playing football
for 120 years that was a really exciting
prospect she can take the card shake it
[Music]
when I first came here I would show
magic tricks the small groups of people
just I introduced myself my head coach
was like yeah so you're gonna do a show
for the team in two weeks it was a big
success so every year afterwards that
was sort of my role on the team other
than long snapping I would I would do a
preseason shot every year just to lift
the team spirits during pre-season which
would be really difficult so I would say
my favorite moment playing for Columbia
football was my junior year homecoming
game it was against Penn and up until
that point we had never beaten them at
least in my career and we were
undefeated at that point 20,000 people
showed up for the game and our stands
only hold 17,000 people so it was packed
and then we were losing up until
halftime but we rallied back and tied up
the game and so we went into overtime
and then as soon as the ref signaled
that it was a touchdown we all stormed
the field so did the crowd and the
stadium blasted all I do is win and we
were all just jumping on the field that
far away was my favorite moment playing
for a Columbia Poppa after I graduated
from Columbia my plan is to pursue a
career as an NFL long snapper I have no
idea when that journey is gonna end it
could end in a month from now or it
could end ten years from now but
whatever that's over my plan is to go to
graduate school and then become a
practicing clinical psychologist